I remember I was working at a restaurant
they had a bus boy there that was an
older guy and he was doing steroids and
it uh and so we would go to the gym
together and next thing you know it was
just like something we did right you
know and um and he was older than me
this guy so sometimes I went looking
back I wonder would I have done it if it
wasn't like an older person if it had
just been a buddy I don't think too much
on it but sometimes I just like to look
back at like you know where was like the
influence coming from or was the
influence coming from inside of me like
wanting something
um different or wanting a different
experience you know wanting to like put
anything into myself right to replace
something inside of me that was missing
you know yeah which is a story of Our
Lives totally right later in life I
could really seeing something that's
already inside of me yeah but I'm
looking for external answers or external
things to fill that void oh it's really
the answers inside of me right yeah but
it doesn't feel like it is because it
feels like there's nothing inside it
once you get silver clear-headed and
kind of can start reflecting on life as
you get older yeah that's when at least
for me my experiences I start to see
I was like the dog chasing my tail yeah
looking for this looking for that and
it's like the whole answer is like with
me the whole time yeah it's just like
stop take a look slow down you know
breathe and yeah but the Catalyst for
the actual steroid taking was I couldn't
bench 315 because that's three big
plates on each side oh yeah but I could
do 295 for like five reps but I couldn't
do 315 for once it was like a
psychological block and I got on like
some really light stairways and like
within two weeks I was like at three
benching like 325. damn so I was like
they definitely were well we got on some
Vietnamese [__] one time I don't even
help me lift it helped me cook it
definitely helped me like I could run a
lot dude I'm not even joking I could
cook over a fire suddenly in my yard but
I could not [__] do it because we got
some gutter steroids that came through
man like we got like bottom of the bear
was it like top of it taped clothes
it wasn't even sealed and stuff
we all went to Mexico on a class trip so
we came back literally people would buy
starts and then put them in shampoo
bottles just kind of rinsing not a
little no and just pour it in there oh
my God so then for like people are just
pulling up at this dude's house and just
syringe and out of this you know Head
and Shoulders unreal you know and that's
it I mean it got you it got you both of
those yeah Pharmaceuticals
holy smokes but yeah we had some of the
cleanest muscles in town right we'll say
that well you're willing to go to any
lengths right oh totally that's the
question that it's like I really was
yeah and so was I and I am today too in
in certain areas of my life but it was
like
I'm going to do whatever I got to do to
be the best player I can be within re
like within the rules right but
steroids or regular rules so those were
within the rules of the time no no they
were breaking the rules they were yeah
they were so and so there was a day
where I had to make a conscious decision
it's like I'm not going to kill I'm not
gonna sit here and lie to myself because
I wasn't like hooked on painkillers I
wasn't drinking alcoholically or nothing
like that at that time I was like
is it worth it hmm
and it was and it I it was yeah I mean
looking back at everything and and you
know what it was worth it and the least
amount of that worth it is monetary even
though it made me it helped me make
millions of dollars right the least the
greatest worth and value in that are the
Lessons Learned in Life from taking them
but at the time you didn't know that
though right but I had to make a
conscious decision on will ever look
back and regret and saying like what
could I have been ah you know what I'm
saying so I was like I'm gonna go to any
links plus and this is not to like I'm
not like blaming anybody but the
atmosphere was like you know the end of
the 70s it happened so this was 1983 84.
so who won four championships in the NFL
in the 70s Steelers right I thought it
was amazing that's right remember they
won two in a row or is that Bradshaw
yeah and all those guys and they're like
you know cereal sansky was out there I
don't know him but but Webster and uh
Steve course and all these old linemen
they were I mean all jacked up right and
it was obvious yeah and I was like in my
head and and my brother kind of felt the
same way it was like the only road to
the NFL is through steroids or or at
least it's a spoke in the wheel yeah
and especially I think as a white guy
you got to get us you got to get on
something you know for what I mean just
no just oh I think no you just gotta get
if I'm a white guy I'm getting on
steroids you to play anything listen can
you imagine if you if someone had a drug
for that yeah oh man how rich they'd be
oh yeah the green is bigger well hell we
sell them half of our ads
so yeah give me some samples I remember
one thing that got me
I remember about and I've just we
haven't had anybody in here I don't
think that's EV that has ever done
steroids that I knew of so it's like
it's just for me it's interesting to
talk about because we talk about it on
the podcast sometimes over the years and
um
so I remember being in class one day and
some kid was a new kid in class and he
thought I was going through the the
aisles picking up people's papers or
something for the teacher right and he
thought I was the teacher's husband
and I think because I'd been doing stuff
I was suddenly yeah yeah I just looked
stronger right and you know and I just
you know at that time the thought that
somebody
would you know I would be married to
somebody that knew first of all that
even knew mathematics as well as this
lady did you know like it almost just
was flattering you know
you think that's my wife
this is a real lady over there
um but I just remember that one moment
that like
I don't know I just felt like people saw
me I just felt more confident I felt
stronger my I just and right right then
man those feelings were feelings that I
never had are they good or what oh right
bro they were so good right they were so
good and then uh but you also did the
work you also worked out right oh I was
it we worked out right and I you know
dieted properly and I you know you would
get on milk thistle and all these like
things you would hear about to kind of
take care of yourself
um
but it was definitely like it was
interesting how I went from a few to
asked me two weeks before would you ever
do steroids I just said no way but then
suddenly I was over a line right and for
me in a lot of my areas of life that
that became something sometimes I really
don't want to look at the truth that
there's a lot of lines that I've crossed
in my life that
I probably wish I hadn't you know I
remember thinking oh I'll never hook up
with a married woman you know and then
cross that line just like right things
that like like where you're saying like
setting kind of boundaries or where who
you are and things that you do will and
won't do right I had those things but I
always went past them and then would
live and still probably live with a ton
of the shame from a lot of it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one